come on
[Applause]
yeah lizzo makes the crowd feel very
special at the 2023 Grammys I'm like
damn this is a big deal first the singer
kicks off the performance with a slowed
down version of her grammy-nominated
song about damn time
[Applause]
[Music]
then lizzo takes us all to church as
she's joined by a gospel choir to
perform the title track from her album
special
say you're special I'm so glad that
you're still with us
[Music]
ahead of the show lizzo stunned in this
Peach number a gown complete with a
floral embroidered cape
she even gave fans a sneak peek of her
look before making her big reveal on the
red carpet
woke up this run until somebody in a
video talking about something I posted
in a video if it was a meeting would you
even get offended or is it just because
I'm black and heavy I'm feeling good as
hell
lizzo's no stranger to the Grammy
Spotlight the 34 year old has three
Awards to her name trophies she won in
2020. I mean it takes 10 years to be an
overnight success period like anybody
who just pops up you know definitely
laid the groundwork and um yeah I just
love music I was always going to be a
career musician I just didn't know I was
going to be this one thing's for sure
lizzo's always special in our eyes
[Music]
foreign